on the 6th of May 2023 the coronation of
King Charles III will take place here's
everything you need to know about that
momentous event
[Music]
well it's really not that long to go
between the 6th and the 8th of May being
told to expect a whole range of
celebratory and ceremonial events you'll
see the King on the balcony at
Buckingham Palace for the first time as
Monarch we're going to see Grand
processions through London a concert at
Windsor Castle and of course good old
British Street parties but the big event
on the Saturday of course will take
place right here at Westminster Abbey
with the coronation service
the coronation service will be the
moment that we see the king and Camilla
the queen consort crowns during that
service we will also witness the Monarch
being anointed blessed and consecrated
by the Archbishop of Canterbury it's
also on that day that we're going to see
the big processions and pageantry
starting off with the king's procession
that will bring them here to Westminster
Abbey and on the way back we see the
grand coronation procession which will
end with that balcony moments
well we have been told that the king and
queen consorts are going to be joined by
other members of the royal family on
that balcony on the day exactly who
though they're keeping that under wraps
and that is probably to try and avoid
any controversy over whether Harry and
Megan are going to come over for the
coronation after what they said in that
Netflix documentary and also Harry's
book but you might remember it was
fairly similar for the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee she kept it strictly to working
Royals to try and avoid any negative
stories on the day
yes you are going to get another bank
holiday on the 8th of May because it's
all been signed off by the Prime
Minister but the King after we see the
concert and also the street parties on
Sunday also wants to make Monday a
chance for local communities to get
together so he's encouraging all of us
to take part in a bit of volunteering to
help those who live nearby us
the climax of the ceremony has arrived
when the Archbishop gently sets this
Splendid emblem on the Queen's head
we're still waiting for all the details
about the coronation service but one
thing is for certain it's likely to be
shorter than the Queens in 1953 that
took three hours this time they're
aiming for it to be less than two hours
her procession after the service also
took two hours through the Streets of
London and it's unlikely we'll see
something of that scale again but the
palace are adamant that all the feedback
they've had is that people do want to
see a Grand National event so this
certainly won't be a slimmed down
coronation despite the cost of living
crisis and also we're told that the
cabinet office are likely to be
reviewing nearly a hundred different
roles to see if they are still relevant
to the ceremony today with the King
wanting yes it to be rooted in Tradition
but also to be reflective of Britain's
day
this will be a moment that we haven't
seen for 70 years but this time set
against a hugely different backdrop
economically politically and socially
if we have to pay for your parade we
know that people today are a lot less
deferential when it comes to the royal
family and already the anti-monarchy
campaign group the public have said that
they are planning to carry out protests
on the day it's also going to be a huge
moment for the king an enormous showcase
where he can show what he wants to do
for the good of the United Kingdom and
also the Commonwealth Realms where he is
still King but with that comes a huge
challenge yes people love the pageantry
they love celebrating Britain's Rich
history but others will want to know how
exactly this event is really going to be
inclusive diverse and representative of
the world that we live in day